is that a gun yeah what's up key in the
sting this is Alex from Houston Texas
I got a key understand for you believing
your girl when she says oh you don't
have to do anything for me in
Valentine's Day it's just a Hallmark
holiday personally I believe it's a trap
why because the next time she goes to
work goes out with her friends shows up
at church everybody in the world is
gonna ask her what did Alex do for you
and Valentine's Day and guess how she's
gonna have to answer nothing
Alex did jack [ __ ] for me on Valentine's
Day and then what happened you have to
repay all since who's at home anyway
guys cuter stinging gang gang buzz buzz
oh wow what the for mass shooter he's a
zebra he no match it was just one was
this one mm-hmm
in Thailand nope oh crap there's one
time where's the other one the other one
was a Korean guy way back yeah remember
yeah
yes all right you're right Korea is one
dirty Mexican mass shooters or not what
did you go oh wait I guess you guys have
Muslims cartels yeah whatever you can
hit with 12 bullets two pistols yeah
Yosemite or Yosemite Sam was basically
the first use my god he had a man he was
a ginger maxium from from Guadalajara
yeah yeah he's like a Canelo dude right
again with us in hello and zoo remember
those guys almost got me into that oh
yeah I remember I was getting best too
yeah we also went down a weird road save
that money boy say 4200 though yeah they
set the whole place on fire apparently
Oh was the guys quiet do you get a lot
of bad investment opportunity I didn't
hear my questions either yeah I don't
think he asked a question everybody was
distracted he basically said what
Brendan that he thinks Valentine's is
made-up holiday so what do you think
when your girl agrees not to do anything
on Valentine's Day do you King that or
is she setting a trap well it's her
chicken had friends like girl I told you
[ __ ] lazy hain't doing [ __ ] so you'll
worry about her chicken ass friends you
don't say
yeah please maybe be like eight so if
you're trying to get dinner on Friday
night everyone's packed right so [ __ ]
that know just like we'll go next week
just add a little next week
I don't like that idea what do you got
here Craig Mexican Craig yes celebrate
celebrate early on or later yeah seven
goes in front of him he's awfully thing
about doing something obviously whether
it's for Valentine's Day or not he wants
to do something shoot clay ducks yeah
there you go
they'll be fun that's good man yeah take
a girl shooting could be fun um ah dude
I think that's a true few say let's do
something a different day cuz it's like
saying hey I don't want to take
responsibility on this day I feel like
that's as much of a trap I'm not saying
you you particularly but I'm just saying
like oh we'll do something in April like
between doing [ __ ] and April the girls
thinking yeah I know if we don't do some
of them Valentine's and we doing
something you know unless she has to
work then I think you can get out of it
such a put so much pressure on dude
Sunday girls don't have to do [ __ ] but
dude the other that's more of a holiday
for them the other 364 days you'll have
to care about your girl that's pretty
easy so for a birthday yeah that's two
363 days Christmas Thanksgiving around
61 don't burn 60 to you right now thank
you
362 it's me time yeah dude so not bad
they're asking for one day they want
some chocolate they want some care what
do you don't be a girl Craig Greg's a
savage all right it should be happy you
got some lotion okay rose oil lotion
real okay $4.99 yeah okay that's
something that's nice Chanel my girl and
I we're doing a staycation less cultural
yeah I think you always emotional
riding the whip dog just the hotel yeah
downtown ye like rose petals out and
[ __ ] you know you're so right about that
[ __ ] like they set you up because she
was like last year because this is my
first girlfriend ever
last year yeah yeah but last year she
was like yeah we don't need to get each
other anything and then she got me
something and I was like huh and I
didn't get her nothing and literally
what did she get you though she got me
like this card in like chocolate and
[ __ ] like that she drew it she drew like
me and a black flag heart did yeah she
got you a tawny man she stopped that
route that's your card and some caramels
bro hey I still got the card yeah man of
course you have it in that special thing
under your bed I dunno that's why I keep
them as well I forgot I got our lunch
pail from Target no oh did she want one
yeah for what for lunch that is a great
question
it's very applicable to a lot of Latinos
berlin's the quinceanera can get Kinson
scary bro she's either I'm guessing
really young or really old
you got like a 47 year old no I've done
that though really yeah how did that
work out
that was crazy tell that I had sex with
her at a park in a park with an older
woman an older woman on the park behind
the park man tree on my birthday party
see that's one of the problems of these
sanctuary cities man stop
I was get your girl oh good
what a cheapskate or she could get you a
hotel room what's your birthday with
that one yeah that one was crazy my
sisters make fun of me because I'm not
even joking she had one leg shorter than
the other
did a little hovel my dad's friend had
something like that yeah yeah I've seen
it before
it'll shed one lecture than the other he
would always stand on this one piece of
cement all the time and he would take it
with him in his hand and set it down and
stand let's see that's so thoughtful me
to be even yeah thank you for not being
a distraction pretend like you didn't
see him set it down and stand yeah he
passed away did he yeah he passed me
like 30 years ago here's their peers a
guy who has a question this guy looks
did we do the last did we hell yeah oh
yeah do you do King or sting not doing
anything when your girl says it's okay
oh it's such a trap dude did you know
they're gonna tell their friends they
have nothing to pose I guess get them
something so they shut them shut the
front and there go our female listeners
here's what I think you should do
embrace your lady get your girl a little
birdbath or something fill it with
chocolate fill it with the moose or
something chocolate moose can't catch a
bird outside and let them [ __ ]
in the apartment buddy got your bird get
a dove $26 for a duck you look up price
of local Duff get your girl a dog man
get your girl apparently you guys have
birds Asians at first guys every every
Chinese persons mother has a damn bird
that's true
take us into Bird Ville Till's parakeets
yeah why is it they're awesome
I [ __ ] hate birds damn $15 for a nice
clean to get your girl two pigeons $15
get her [ __ ] get her a 12-piece from
Buffalo Wild Wings you know I'm saying
little extra crispy there's a good
Valentine's Day called the before and
after package you get that living bird
in that dead bird yeah yeah and say look
my love for you is it's been here and
it'll stay here it's a circle
before and after just keep referencing
circles and get to Pigeon yeah get you a
pigeon if you can't get to get a pigeon
and put off if you can't afford a dog
get a pigeon and put on baby powder on
his back you could spray paint that
thing dollars yeah oh you can get a
pigeon for six dollars or if you're fast
you can just get a pigeon
if you're really fast there's nothing
you need to clip their wings just spray
paint them white and they can't really
fly away and wet feathers keep it's a
life cheat oh yeah bro the brown birds
yeah Jim what do you guys do do you guys
eat the animals at some point you guys
is it their burials how do you guys go
actually buried yeah my Birds
amen you bury your Birds yeah you like
do you have like a little coffin you
know we put them in a little shoebox
yeah both of them yeah but a shoebox not
a good idea cuz kind of big when you
want to bury it yeah but that's what we
did but it shakes in there when we won't
yeah both of them they both died at the
same time you know when parakeets died
yeah they died like right after I left
there they're lovebirds they died right
after like old people well I you know
old people they've been together for
like 70 years one gets the flu the other
gets the flu and one dies in like two
days later the other one dies well
that's like a notebook you know a lot of
parents and old trick is you get
hamsters name them after the
grandparents and it prompts kids learn
that grim practice for grandparents
dying
oh that's a good Matt is a good move
it's like here's pop-pop and here's you
know you know grandma Tiffany or
whatever yeah well they passed away -
they're old and that's gonna happen to
your grandma grandpa yeah and you get to
bury them but yeah that case whisk off
and you guys were serving up over there
huh yeah what happened to the Mexican
community with birds died Craig yeah
yeah Barry
do they really that's it y'all dig them
back up yeah and then come back we put
the little skeleton on a necklace and
sell it for five bucks pesos that's a
real business man yeah the bone business
is big real big we just have a guy that
would sell he had the erection bone or
the penal bone of a raccoon and he would
bring him to school and sell them call
him boner necklaces no just was I care
you want these raccoon dick
yeah you need [ __ ] some he's opened
up a handful of and have six or seven
I'm gonna pick one out and I got prized
him around the school he was a B student
he's one of our finer students yeah
price shouldn't be allowed on campus
obese dude I wouldn't call where we went
to school campus there were one is you
price Channel I'm over your house some
of the classrooms had wheels on them
okay one over dude I remember our
science guys had a gas leak at one point
of actual gasoline bro what's Jay did
your high school have the photo room
where is black and white it was like a
purple room you don't talk about weed
weed make your you like take pictures
and then go in there really I would like
the villa darker you just look like
someone took white paint and it gives
the walls is pick these kids are just
busting knots in there man there's no
cameras is all pink was gonna happen
damn I want to go to that school yeah we
have a sick room you would tell your
girl to get sick and you would get sick
and y'all go meet up in there oh that's
dope and just pretend it was so crazy
cuz soon as a teacher would come and
open the door both you guys different
times
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]